這裡是 AI 101，全網最幽默的 AI 新聞
一名可能單獨行動的操作者，用一套 AI
自主滲透測試系統鎖定南韓金融機構同期至少
9 家南韓銀行自行披露或被報導遭鎖定
最後讓調查者掌握線索的
是伺服器開放目錄裡的 AI
對話和一份身分真偽未明的履歷
可是被打開的
並不是銀行最重要的那扇門
核心交易照常運作
出事的是貸款仲介查詢、
外勤業務支援這類外圍系統
大門沒破
客戶資料卻從旁邊的小門流了出去
從小門漏出去的，可不是幾筆資料而已
光是新韓銀行一家
就確認大約2萬5千名客戶受到影響
漏掉的又是哪些資料？
姓名、電話、年收入，還有貸款額度
單獨看好像沒什麼，但拼在一起
就足以量身打造一套詐騙話術
一通電話就叫得出你的名字
那駭客是怎麼露餡的？
資安公司 CrowdStrike 發現
他的伺服器目錄沒上鎖
裡面有 Claude Code 工作階段、
Claude 記憶檔，還有中文寫的提示
像一本沒闔上的工作筆記
這本筆記裡最核心的工具，叫 ARTEX
一套開源的 AI 自主滲透測試系統
能讓一個人指揮多個 AI 代理分工作業
ARTEX 的說明寫明限個人學習用途
這次卻被拿來濫用
工具再厲害，挑目標的還是人
沒有證據顯示 AI 自己選中南韓銀行
目標是操作者決定的，AI 只是幫忙偵察、
滲透，替他跑腿
那操作者拿到資料想做什麼？
他問過 AI，韓國外洩資料通常在哪裡賣
還有怎麼找 Telegram 上的交易群
這支持以金錢為動機的判斷
但目前沒有證據顯示資料已經賣出
更有反差的是，同一批 ARTEX 成果
他轉頭又叫 Claude
寫進一份資安研究員履歷
前一刻還在找地方賣資料
下一刻就包裝成求職成就
可是這份履歷，也不能拿來認人
同一批紀錄裡，一處寫26歲
另一處卻填2007年出生
換算下來大約19歲
年齡前後打架，不能當成真實身分
也因為線索對不上
CrowdStrike 只用中等信心判斷：
操作者可能說中文，以金錢為動機
CrowdStrike
也沒有把這次行動歸到任何國家頭上
那南韓警方呢？
警方桌上是28個 IP
分布在至少12個國家
但大多只是用來藏身的代理和中繼點
比起這些假面
駭客自己留下的 AI 對話和記憶檔
反而成了新的指紋
把兩條線索放在一起看
AI 可能讓單一操作者同時指揮多個代理
做出過去像大型團隊才有的產能
可是留紀錄、管伺服器、藏身分的紀律
未必跟著升級
駭客的身分還在查，銀行的帳也要算了
10月19日
5家銀行的行長要到南韓國會的國政監查
說明連環外洩和資安投資的責任：
為什麼守住了核心大門
卻讓外圍系統成了漏資料的小窗